تعمل الان
فوق طاقتها الاستعابيه الكادر الطبي وحتى
السعه بالنسبه للمصابين مشفى عفرين المشفى
المشفى العسكري في عفرين اضافه الى
المستشفى في عقيربات بريف ادلب الى مستشفى
باب الهوى وبعض النقاط الطبيه التي تقوم
باستيعاب المصابين والذين يتم نقلهم من
تحت الانقاذ بالحديث عن الانقاذ والعاملين
في هذا المجال لا يزال فرق لا تزال فرق
الدفاع المدني تلعب دور راس الحربه اضافه
الى المدنيين الذين تطوعوا بشكل مباشر
بادوات بدائيه وبسيطه من محاوله منهم
الانتشار المصابين تحت الانقاذ المباني
المنهاره ولكن
هي محاذيه للحدود التركيه وايضا تحت سيطره
تركيا او نفوت تركي لافت في تلك المناطق
هل سمح للمصابين او لفرق الاسعاف
بنقل المصابين الى المستشفيات داخل
الاراضي تركي نعم هناك الحالات الحرجه
التي يتم نقلها مباشره من المشاكل السوريه
الى المشاكل التركيه مرورا بالحدود
السوريه التركيه هناك عمليه تسهيل او
عمليه تسهيل لدخول المصابين من الحالات
الحرجه اما الحالات المتوسطه يتم معالجتها
داخل النقاط الطبيه والمستشفيات في سوريا
ومنهم من يطلب منه الخروج داخل النقاط
الطبيه بعد تلقي العلاج ليكون هناك مساحه
لشخص اخر يتم نقله او ادخاله من اجل تلقي
العلاج خاصه ان العديد من النقاط الطبيه
والمستشفيات حقيقه بلاونه الاخيره وكنت قد
تحدثت في وقت سابق على شاشتكم الكريمه
بتوقف الدعم الطبي للعديد من المستشفيات
المتواجده في ادلب وريفه لذلك هناك نقص
بالمعدات الطبيه لا تحدث عن نقص ايضا في
الكادر الطبي بقدر المعدات والمستلزمات
الطبيه حاليا من اجل اسعاف المدنيه او
تقديم لهم الاسعافات الاوليه الحالات
الصعبه يتم تحويلها بورقه مباشره من من
المستشفيات المختصه داخل الاراضي السوريه
عبر سيارات الاسعاف الى داخل الاراضي
التركيه حيث يتم وضعها بالسيارات اسعاف
تركيا بمعابر او بنقاط التواصل ما بين هذه
المستشفيات ويتم نقلها الى المستشفيات
التركيه التي ايضا لديها نصيبها من
الاصابات ومن القتلى